determine whether the points on this
graph represent a function now just as a
refresher a function is really just an
association between members of a set
that we call the domain and members of a
set that we call a range so if I take
any member of the domain let's call that
X and I give it to the function the
function should tell me what member of
my range is that associated with it so
it should point to some other value this
is a function it would not be a function
if it says well it could point to Y or
or it could point to Z or maybe it could
point to e or whatever else this would
not be a function because over here so
this right over here not a function not
a function because it's not clear if you
input X what member of the range you're
going to get in order for it to be a
function it has to be very clear for
anymore any input into the function you
have to be very clear that you're only
going to get one output now with that
out of the way let's think about this
function that is defined graphically so
the range is or I should say the domains
the valid inputs are the x-values where
this function is defined so for example
it tells us if X is equal to negative 1
if we assume that this over here is the
x axis and this is the y axis it tells
us when X is equal to negative 1 we
should output or out or Y is going to be
equal to 3 so one way to write that
mapping is you could say you could say X
when you input it let me write it this
way negative 1 if you take negative 1
and you input it into our function I'll
put a little F box right over there
you will get you will get the number 3
this is our X and this is our Y so that
seems reasonable negative 1 very clear
that you get 2 3 let's see what happens
when we go over here if you put 2 into
the function when X is 2 y is negative 2
once again when X is 2 the function
associates to 4x which is a member of
the domain it's defined for 2 it's not
defined for 1 we don't know what our
function is equal to it 1 so it's not
defined there so 1 isn't part of the
domain 2 is it tells us when X is
- then why is going to be equal to
negative two so it Maps it or associates
it with negative two that doesn't seem
too troublesome just yet now let's look
over here our function is also defined
at X is equal to three it associates
three our function associates or Maps
three to the value y is equal to two Y
is equal to two that seems pretty
straightforward and then we get to X is
equal to four where it seems like this
thing that could be a function it is the
it is somewhat defined it does try to
associate four with things but what's
interesting here is it tries to
associate four with two different things
all of a sudden in this thing that we
think might have been a function but it
looks like it might not be we don't know
do we associate four with five do we
associate with five or do we associate
it with negative one so this thing right
over here is actually a relation you can
have you can have one member of the
domain being related to multiple members
of the range but if you do have that
then you're not dealing with the
function so once again because of this
this is not not a function it's not
clear that when you input X when you
input four into it should you output
five or should you output negative one
and sometimes there's something called
the vertical line test that tells you
whether something is a function when
it's graphically defined like this you
literally say okay when X is four if I
draw a vertical line do I intersect the
function at two places or more it could
be two or more places and if you do that
means that there's two or more values
that are related to that that value in
the domain there's two or more outputs
for the input four and if there are two
or more outputs for that one input then
you're not dealing with a function
you're just dealing with a relation a
function is a special case of a relation
or you could view it as a well behaved
relation